- Fruits, fruits, fruits, fruits.
Natural sugar is what this video's about.
(upbeat tropical music)
- Guava, oh I dropped it!
- You can eat the rind of a guava?
- I don't know if I wanna eat the rind.
- Well do I eat the seeds?
- You could bust up some
teeth with these seeds.
- Ah!
I like cracked a tooth there.
- Oh my god, that is really good.
- Guava me some more fruits.
- [Voiceover] Tamarind!
- Ooh!
- The exoskeleton is very weak.
- It looks like chocolate.
(sniffs)
But it smells like
these vitamins I used to
give my pet lizard.
- This looks really weird.
Like it's veiny.
- But it's like a really nice, sweet sap.
- It has like a date, figgy taste.
- Am I doing this right?
- [Voiceover] Lychee.
- Cracking open a can of eyeballs.
- Kind of reminds me of those fruit snacks
my mom used to pack.
- These taste so much
better than they look.
You could definitely sip
up the juices in this can.
- Ooh that's good.
I like that a lot.
- Oh my gosh, that's incredible.
It's like a pineapple but better.
- Lychee desserts, like a lychee pie.
Has anyone done that?
Will somebody do that?
Should I do that?
- [Voiceover] Dragon fruit.
- This is not fruit, this is art.
- This is the fruit that everyone should
Instagram themselves eating.
- This is giving me like kiwi vibes.
- It takes me to the ocean.
- Please don't judge me.
- It's kinda like all show, no flavor.
- It's good, I just feel
like I'm eating air.
- By looks though, this takes the cake.
I need to decorate my place so
if you have some more of these
I'll just put them in
various places in my house.
- Jackfruit named after Jack?
- What's up with all these cans?
- Oh ugh, it's kind of aggressive.
- It's a little rubbery.
- Let's see how its juice is.
- Taste-wise, it's really good.
- No, I like the lychee better.
- Now Stevefruit would
probably be pretty good.
- [Voiceover] Dude what is that?
- It's like a fruit mush
wrapped in a condom.
- This is a fruit?
- This is just making
me sad, looking at this.
- It smells like rotten cantaloupe.
- It smells like garlic.
- I don't like that.
Can I have a lychee please?
- Well actually it's grown on me.
Ooh it's got a great aftertaste.
- This is like really good.
- I'm pleasantly surprised.
You know what?
Good things come in nasty packages.
Okay.
- [Voiceover] Oh yes!